I'm starting today with something that is the
perfect nexus of ignorance and nationalism,
I think is the way I would put it, the unhinged
nationalism, in fact, of some of the new Trumpy
and members of Congress really knows no bounds.
And it even now is being applied to American
territories whose residents are citizens of the
United States. And I'm talking about none other
than radical, outrageous, disgusting, depraved and
delusional. Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green,
of course, of Jewish space laser fame, she said at
a side panel, a sort of breakout session at CPAC
a couple of weeks ago, that American taxpayer
money shouldn't go to foreign countries like
wait for it, Guam. Now, Guam is, of course,
an American territory. The people of Guam are
American citizens. The reason it took us a couple
of weeks to hear about this, even though CPAC was
a couple of weeks ago, is that it was at one of
these breakout sessions. So what we watched on TV
from CPAC, that wasn't all. They also had breakout
sessions with smaller groups where a lot of the
things I said were even nuttier and even more
ignorant, if you can imagine that it was filmed.
Here is Marjorie Taylor Green saying no
more money for foreign countries like
Guam, where everybody's an American citizen.
And I wanted to take my regular person, normal,
everyday American values, which is we love our
country. We believe our hard earned tax dollars
should just go for America, not for what China,
Russia, the middle class. If we want to put money
into schools, if we want to build a border wall,
we want it right here at home, no more money
for foreign countries like Guam.
This reminded me, of course,
and I think it reminded many, many others
of the whole Puerto Ricans should go back to
their country. Puerto Ricans, of course, are
American. There is no country to go back to.
It's part of the United States. And on a serious
note, this really does reinforce the importance of
normalizing the status of places like Puerto Rico
and Guam and others. Green, as an elected official
should know what is part of the United States and
what is not. But this is also another reminder, as
if we needed one, that the way we deal with Puerto
Rico and Guam and others like American Samoa,
it really makes no sense. In many ways. We do
treat them as if they are foreign countries.
There are different statuses for different
territories. People born on American Samoa,
for example, are U.S. nationals, but they're not
U.S. citizens. People from Puerto Rico and Guam
are U.S. citizens at birth. It's a mess and it
needs to be fixed. But what foreign country does
she think Guam is anyway? Now, Marjorie Taylor
Green is a moron. Yes, she has no business being
in the House of Representatives. And this proves
that there needs to be serious consideration given
to the status of overseas territories. She's
in Congress. She should know, without a doubt.
But the truth is, if you ask your average person
in the street, is Guam its own country or a U.S.
territory, many people would have no idea. This
isn't completely unique to the United States. I
think if you go to the UK and you ask people about
some of the more obscure British territories,
I think many people in the UK also wouldn't know.
But the issue is people in government should know.
And these territories, as far as the U.S. is
concerned, do not have adequate representation
in their own government. So it's particularly
it's a it's a vicious cycle when they don't
have adequate representation. And then our elected
officials sometimes don't even know that they are
lacking the representation because they don't
even know that it's part of the United States
unless it's convenient for some
other reason. Like, for example,
when Republicans want to talk about how bad a job
a Democratic president is doing on controlling
North Korea, they will say North Korea could hit
U.S. territories with missiles like Guam, then
it's convenient. Then all of a sudden they figure
out Guam is a U.S. territory. There are many
Americans who don't realize Puerto Rico's part of
the US. Puerto Ricans are U.S. citizens. There are
some Americans who think New Mexico is part of
Mexico rather than a US state. There's plenty of
ignorance to go around, but Marjorie Taylor Green
is an elected official and it's very politically
relevant. So just another confirmation that she
has no business, no business whatsoever serving
in government. And hopefully she will either not
run for reelection in 2022 or be voted out in a
bloodbath election. Let's hope for the latter.
I think it would be more more entertaining.